breaking news here at 4 30. we've been
monitoring a heavy police presence at
the Turnberry Towers after an apparent
shooting is now investigator Kyle Payne
has just arrived at the scene and joins
us now live with what he can tell us
Kyle
Kirsten the police presence outside the
area here is rather small but inside
behind the Gates where that circular
driveway is the police presence is
rather large many police cruisers and
lately we've been seeing more Cruisers
that are unmarked to go in the telltale
signs of Investigation Metro did confirm
earlier that someone was shot and
transported for medical care however we
don't know that person's condition what
we do know is that we spoke with some
neighbors who all confirmed the same
little series of events that they heard
gunshots about six seven or eight of
them that they were terrified that it
was frightening one of them who lives in
the East Tower where this alleged
shooting may have occurred says that the
doorman told him to get out and that
neighbor says that that doorman may have
saved his life right now we're efforting
the um reporting of more information but
for now this is Kyle Payne reporting
live on Karen Ave near Paradise 8 News
Now